all right great thank you everyone we're
going to be starting again as i
mentioned just one more
minute we're still expecting a couple
more people to join
good morning everyone and welcome to
this program
this is an introduction to a program
that is starting today called
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
and this program is going to be hosted
at the university of ghana
but in general we'll talk about how
bioinformatics can be used in the
context
of infectious diseases and the
host pathogen interaction so those of
you that have not
yet registered to the program you'll see
an overview of how
you can complete your registration but
you will also be able to learn about
general application of bioinformatics to
the study of
viruses uh micro and other
microorganisms that cause
human disease and we're excited that all
of you are joining
hopefully i will be able to answer most
of your questions and if not i will also
point you to a number of resources that
we have available
for all of you that are joining today
so let's start by talking about briefly
this program
bioinformatics for infectious disease is
a program
that is specifically designed for those
interested in conducting research
using bioinformatics tools so we'll talk
about where to find data how to analyze
such
data what to do with your analysis
results in terms of biological
interpretation
and our main objective here is to
provide a
support system for those of you
interested in leveraging bioinformatics
analysis tools
to really get to a place where you can
get a publication or maybe a poster
presentation
and you're making progress in terms of
research outcomes so that's the main
objective
uh what we'll do today is we'll review
uh all of these different resources that
will be included
we'll also take a look at a number of
different sessions that are going to be
coming up so that you're aware of
the schedule and how things are going to
be organized and what's the expectation
what are some of the dates
and hopefully we'll be able to answer
any questions that you have
both about the program itself and about
the outcomes how to get to those
outcomes that we'll talk about
now i'm going to be guiding this
particular session but i want to mention
that this program
first of all the oversight and the
development of the resources and tools
are going to be overseen by the
university of haifa
tower bioinformatics research center so
this research center
is a research center focused on
bioinformatics tools and algorithms
they specialize in developing novel
algorithms
that we will be reviewing and using
during the sessions that we have
uh it is uh guided by dr lenin brodsky
and dr alfred tauber
both of them with extensive research
experience and collaborations
uh but also we have a dedicated team
that is supporting our training
activities helping with all of the
technical resources that we have and
maintain a whole community of thousands
of users from around the world
that are learning bioinformatics and
applying those to a variety of different
topics so
at the end of this session you will be
able to learn about some of the
additional programs that we are
launching in february that include
programs on metagenomics genomics
different types of applications of those
as well and in different locations for
example
in nigeria in louisiana in the us
and in india so how do these sessions
work um i'm sure that most of you are
already familiar with how we kind of
operate we have a number of uh kind of
resources that work together to make
these sessions effective
first of all we have our interactive
sessions which is
something that you'll experience today
uh hopefully it is
interactive in the sense that it's not
just going to be me speaking but we'll
also
hear from some of you and learn about
your background and your interests
but also we have a number of guided
materials that you can go through
to learn about different types of data
different tools for analysis
and how to conduct a research study
using
bioinformatics analysis tools and so
we'll review a little bit of how these
guided materials are organized and how
we can make those
into a part of a session in other words
we will show you how the activity of
your progress through those asynchronous
resources is tracked
and how do we use it to make sure that
we address the topics that everybody
has questions about or is struggling
with
the final one are the practical
assignments so these practical
assignments
are really an introduction to research
tools and
bioinformatics is a comprehensive
name of a whole field of research
where we use databases analytical tools
visualization of data interpretation of
data right so there are many components
to bioinformatics so
these practical assignments are designed
to introduce you
in to some cloud-based big data analysis
tools
but also some practical skills how to
manage your data how to effectively
visualize annotate
and work with your data so it's going to
include some coding
some big data analysis tools and
hopefully i'll clarify this in just a
few more minutes
now the sessions are guided by a number
of people and so
these are your main contacts i'm going
to introduce
all of us now so that you're familiar
with our team
and then i'll ask you a few questions
about you so that
we can also get to know you so first of
all you probably are already familiar
with
beeps this was she's our community
manager and responsible for logistics
and accounts
and you'll be getting a lot of emails
from her so as this program
starts it's important for you to make
sure that you have her
email address saved in your contacts
which is marketing at pine dot bio
this is an important contact because she
will be sending you
a lot of information about recordings of
the sessions that we complete
information about upcoming sessions as
well as any assignments and additional
resources that you should have access to
and so if you have any questions about
your login
about your account about how to use
something she would be
the person who can direct your info your
questions to the right person
or answer them herself the second person
on our team
is dr harpreet kaur she has a phd in
bioinformatics and specialized in
genomics specifically in cancer but she
is
very well versed in all of the methods
of analysis that we have
on the t-violin for platform so for any
technical assistance
questions about methods how to run those
methods
issues with your input data or output
data
please also add her into your contacts
her email is
support pine dot bio thank you beeps
that you can find those email addresses
in the chat box dr mahit mazumdar
is our project mentor he will help you
work with available data on public
domain
repositories identify that data
make sure that you understand how that
data has been generated
and help you translate your idea about
how to research that particular
uh data set into a research question
so you can also uh find him on
his email which is mojit at pine dot bio
so he will be helping you and guiding
you for
the different projects that you have
already maybe thought of
or you're starting to think about and
develop throughout this program
my name is elia brodsky so i'm going to
be helping
by conducting some of the live sessions
and also helping you
uh by linking you to the right resources
that we have on our platforms on the
different
websites that we operate and also i
could help
by providing some feedback on the
research projects
as they develop or any other technical
questions that you might have
a lot of times i will leverage our
collaborators at the tower
bioinformatics research center
and getting you good information from
them to answer
any scientific questions that you might
have so let me tell you a little bit
more about our team
what is their background and what do
they really specialize in
dr mohit mazumdar has over 10 years of
experience has got his phd in
bioinformatics or chemo informatics
primarily he now works with a number of
faculty
and university contacts as well as
industry contacts that we have
but his phd was focused on developing a
method to identify and predict
calcium binding sites and study binding
affinity
with calcium so he had to really master
data mining and become proficient at
predictive modeling
so he would be especially helpful once
you get to
one of the sessions where we will
discuss
structures how proteins interact with
different ligands how proteins interact
with other proteins
how do we deal with structural biology
questions
even though he's also familiar with the
number of other applications of
bioinformatics that we will cover
like analysis of ngs data
now as i mentioned uh dr horpita or
she has her phd in
focused on prognosis of liver cancer
identifying biomarkers and primarily her
expertise
is with genomic and transcriptomic data
so you'll find her expertise primarily
on how to analyze
big data how to apply machine learning
to
gene expression data genomic data how to
integrate data through multi-omics
integration methods
and how to develop a sense of what are
the specific features in that data that
are most insightful that are most
important for our ability to
differentiate between different
disease stages or disease conditions
or maybe different types of population
representatives
so that is her background now
i told you a little bit about our team i
would like now to also
ask you about your background so i'm
going to launch
a poll uh this poll will will
ask you the following question so first
of all
sorry one second that should be
later so first of all what
country are you from uh
so we have a number of countries that we
expected people to
be from including ghana nigeria
india usa or maybe other so
if your answer is other then please
put in the answer into the chat box uh
beeps
uh do you see the poll is the poll live
now
yes yeah it's live now okay
so please answer uh the question number
one
is which country are you from
now the second question is about the
city which city are you from
uh we also anticipated a couple of
cities we don't know exactly where
you're from but
lagos kolkata accra in ghana
or delhi or new orleans boston or maybe
other
so please you can if you don't see
i don't see any answers right now in the
poll yet but
please respond in the poll you if it's
other just click on other and then
you'll be able to
put in the response there
okay university so again
this program is primarily hosted
by the university of ghana
um and the people from that university
we have that answer in the poll uh
university of ghana
louisiana state university haifa
university or
other so please put your responses again
in the poll number four
is about your degree so your degree
could be
bachelor's master's phd
or other and
then another couple of questions
research interest
so your interest could be in virology
microbiology genomics bioinformatics
or other and then
what is your background your background
could be
researcher so the background the
background could be
researcher student faculty
industry or other so again this is a
poll you should be able to see the poll
and so please
add your information from
answering the questions in the poll i'll
give you a couple of moments
here to answer all of these questions i
know that it's a lot but it's a good way
to get to know everyone and really
understand
our audience a little bit better
okay great so what we're seeing is we
have about over
50 of the participants here are
currently researchers
and so that's great to know um and uh
other um about seven to ten percent are
faculty
uh so that's great um now i'll
leave this poll on for now but i'll
continue with my slides and the primary
thing that i wanted to
get to is that we have uh
this free course called introduction to
bioinformatics
and the reason why we start with this
course
one of the reasons is because it is a
course where we
have a survey in the survey a lot of the
same information is being asked
and thank you beeps for putting that in
the chat box so let me
show you how to access this course
uh please go with me to edu dot
t bio dot info so this is the link
okay thank you pizza and let me know
once you're there
okay you can put yes or i'm there
or number one
and yes just again about uh the poll
answers if you could please use the poll
uh to answer the question uh so that way
we'll have a structured data set at the
end and we can
review the data together with our
collaborators thank you
right
okay thank you so if you're here this is
a website
where we store a lot of our asynchronous
materials
including uh some of the important
information for this program itself
so if you don't have enough account
already you need to create an account
if you are from the university of ghana
and you have registered for the program
through university of ghana
your account information should have
been sent out to you so please use that
use that information to sign in and i'll
just briefly show you once you're here
you can go to courses and this is the
course that i'm asking you to take a
look at
it's called introduction to
bioinformatics and this is
a course that on one hand is a course
designed for beginners maybe
you're thinking i am already a
researcher or a faculty i know a lot
about bioinformatics and
we of course understand that we're not
saying that this is going to be some
revolutionary course but it's a free
resource
and one of the important things in this
course is that it has an
intro survey in this intro survey
we collect information about the users
primarily to identify
major trends and interests of the people
that are
joining our program so as a part of this
infectious disease program
you will see some of this information
that we already collected in the poll
but you're welcome to submit that
information again because we're also
interested in your bioinformatics
experience
in your general background why you want
to learn bioinformatics or maybe
already learning bioinformatics what
would you expect to take away from these
courses
and if there's anything else that you
would like to share for example
some specific type of interest that you
have
and we haven't mentioned it in the
survey you can
ask that or you can answer that right
there
okay so again please take a look at this
course
and we hope to learn more about all of
the participants here
now the other thing that you will notice
is that we
have uh in this portal a
way to really tie in all of the progress
that
we are going to be doing in this program
into your profile
so i'm giving here an example of a
profile somebody that has previously
completed our bioinformatics for
infectious disease program
and i want to mention that it's really
an impactful
part of completing your profile to make
sure
that your certification is up to date in
other words when you complete a
course you will get an automatically
generated certificate
that certificate could be shared on
social media it could be used for other
purposes
but it's important that your full name
the way that you would like it to be
on your certificate is spelled out right
here right so for example
this is going to be your username once
you sign up but this
is going to be your full name now it's
also interesting for us to know
if you're a faculty or you're part of a
company or something like that that you
add that information right here
and we anticipate many of you to have a
social media profile
on facebook on linkedin on other
platforms so please add
that information there as well and beeps
also posted
a link in the chat box on how to
complete your
profile so here we would like to
ask all of you to take some time maybe
after the session
add that information in there now once
you have completed your registration for
the program
you will also see a badge and this badge
is an
indication that you're a part of the
program and so for the duration of that
program
this badge is going to be available
after you complete the program you will
get a certificate
and i will show you in your profile
where you will see all of that
information including
your certificate of course completion
your certificate of program completion
and as you prepare a project of your own
also your project is going to be added
there as well
now once you have made your
profile on the tb is platform we also
invite you to join our social media
groups and these groups are not just for
us to
you know share updates this is an
important place where we share
uh different job openings so if you're
looking for a career in bioinformatics
there's a lot of
positions open there are a lot of
collaborative projects as well
so you will find information about
different resources
important updates about our programs but
also other programs and other resources
that are out there
and we hope that you can join these
programs again beeps have posted the
social media links
in the chat box so you can find those
there please do connect with us so you
will find
uh myself uh dr mazumdar dr
khaor biebsa and everybody else that
works for our company
uh listed in those groups as well so we
hope to connect with you on social media
stay in touch and hopefully share
updates about this program and others
as you join
okay so let's talk about bioinformatics
for
infectious diseases so again this is a
program
that is intended to support research
projects through training so we're going
to do some training we're going to do
some exercises
and to explain how these exercises are
organized
in this session i will give you a sense
of what those
exercises will be and how to find
project examples that illustrate the
impact
of these different types of analysis
techniques
so first of all we'll talk about
sequence variation
and alignment so you're probably
familiar with
methods of aligning two sequences which
is called pairwise alignment
or multiple sequences msa
but we'll take a look at some of the
importance of
different types of variants and
different types of
mutations that cause changes in the
amino acids
maybe that cause stop codons to appear
and we'll think about how to find this
important variation
especially when we deal with complex
sequencing so we'll talk about sequences
of
individual genes or regions as well as
full genomes and we'll talk about the
consequence of that
now another part of sequence alignment
is the reconstruction of the
evolutionary tree so we'll talk a little
bit about
phylogenetic analysis and how these
sequences
can inform us about the molecular clock
and how they could have originated from
a common ancestor
and how do we piece that information
together we'll talk about how to map
such genomic variation onto protein
structure
and explore the structure changes using
3d representation of these proteins
produced by cryom microscopy
we'll talk about also transcriptomic
analysis of host response
so we'll take a look at how do we
analyze the impact
that is uh for example in the context of
the disease
on the host and what are some of those
genes that are differentially expressed
how do we map that onto a pathway
how do we interpret the analysis results
but before we jump into these specific
topics
let's talk a little bit about infectious
and
non-infectious diseases so an infection
is the invasion of an organism's body
tissues by disease-causing agents
their multiplication or replication and
the reaction of host tissues to the
infectious agent
and the toxins that they produce so an
infectious disease
is also primarily known as transmissible
disease or communicable disease
which is an illness resulting from an
infection so
one of the major components of
infectious diseases
as opposed to non-infectious diseases is
that one
they are caused by a pathogen and two
that they are
shared from multiple between multiple
people or between multiple hosts
non-infectious diseases are not caused
by a pathogen
cannot be shared from one person to
another and are caused by other factors
such as
environment nutritional deficiencies
lifestyle choices or genetic inheritance
so because we are separating these
bioinformatics programs into different
categories
this is one of the reasons why we want
to focus specifically on infectious
diseases because
the topics that we will go over
include different pathogens and you can
see some of the examples here like flu
hiv malaria and we'll talk about the
impact on the host right you can see
that right here for example sickle cell
disease
or we can talk about how the reaction to
different toxin happens
so what are some of the important things
that we will discuss in the context of
the program
we'll talk about replication and or
colonization
so we'll talk about how does that
process happen we'll talk about the
result to the
host cells for example cell death how
does that happen
as a result of what and the release of
toxins and how the impact of cell death
and the release of toxins has an impact
on
organ function interference and damage
to interference with that normal
function
now another important part that we'll
talk about is
the response right and so our bodies
have
uh these uh uh response mechanisms
uh that include different ways that our
body
deals with these intruders and we'll
talk about how
the immune system has several different
types of responses
these responses can be uh trained
or induced and that is really the basis
for
many of the interventions that we are
going to look at and we're going to look
at how those interventions work
in different patients or in different
examples
and we'll also take a look at how those
responses could be induced and what are
some examples
of uh such interventions so as you know
vaccines um are one of the first
types of interventions that has been
introduced and it has been introduced
as far as back as the earth early 1800s
and so you know it's been a long time
since the concept of vaccination has
been introduced but as you can see in
this chart
below that is not the only way
that disease burden has been reduced
in fact we can see that other types of
interventions for example
we can see antibacterial
penicillin we can see here
the vaccine that was introduced and
we also see other types of interventions
for example
continuous municipal use of chlorine in
water in the united
states right so in the context of the
history of
dealing with infectious diseases there
have been major
progress and major successes at the same
time
there now we know that that has not been
the solution to everything that is out
there so in fact
with covet 19 we are reminded once again
of how morbid this infectious disease
as a pandemic can be even with all of
the tools that we have at our disposal
so while the history of dealing with
infectious diseases
is full of successes that we can
celebrate we can also
be reminded about the continuous need to
study
microorganisms and infectious diseases
develop
novel ways to resolve them but
also develop technologies that help us
understand
how infectious diseases are
causing disease and where do they come
from where they originate
from so one of the ways that we will
look at uh this we will see
that uh while in the beginning one of
the primary
tools that we had to understand
microorganisms was the microscope
but today we have additional types of
information
like genomic sequencing that really
helps us
address the impact of infectious
diseases
understand virulence of these different
pathogens understand their protein
expression
understand how to diagnose them more
precisely
insights into the molecular mechanisms
that they
interact with the host and with the
vectors and
also understand how how do they evolve
how do they change from
a pathogen that might not cause such a
harmful effect
to a pathogen that could be very deadly
so what are
the processes as well as what are the
specific manifestations
of those processes so we'll take a look
at these different technologies like
sequencing
and we'll start seeing how do we apply
those in the context of
specific project examples so one
can also think about differences in
viral
responses we can think about different
strains
we can think about different types of
responses
and a lot of that information could be
captured
from sequencing but of course sequencing
could be of many different types
and the important part for us is we will
take a look at how
from sequence data we can start looking
at
structural analysis we can look at gene
expression studies
and as the data becomes available
determine
patterns that could be impactful for our
detailed understanding of protein
protein interaction
as well as single cell level response to
these different pathogens
and how do we piece all that data
together
so to really take a look at such a
diverse
range of topics we have prepared a
number of
different examples and in those examples
we'll take a look at
viral genomics and evolution we will
take a look at
microbiome and the infection through the
microbiome
we'll also take a look at different
examples of immune response biomarkers
to understand how this process happens
now before we go on i wanted to make
sure that i
do pauses as i said the intent of these
sessions
is to create a an interaction
right and not only kind of a lecture so
i'm really looking forward to
learning more about your interests and
to understand
whether some of these topics that we
raise i'm going to be at pausing
and asking if you have any questions now
as we go through and you have again
non-technical questions
uh you can post them in the chat and
beeps should be able to respond to those
directly if you do have questions about
the topics that i go through in the
slides
this would be the opportunity to hear
what your questions might be
so again if you have any questions
right now you can put those in the chat
and in the meantime
i am going to share the results of
the poll beep say can you see the
results of the poll
yes celia i can see the results of the
poll
so for the first question which is what
country are you from
so we have 30 percent of attending
participants who are from ghana
seven person participants are from
nigeria
india has about 26 percent attendance
and we have two person from the us as
well and 36 percent of participants
which is the largest
number are from other countries
and some of those countries which are
mentioned in the chat box were pakistan
brazil
and a few other countries so
if you still want to add your country
you can or
your city or your
department and name you can again put
that in the chat box if you have not
answered
going to the second question what city
are you from
so we have 26 percent of participants
who are from accra
two person from lagos to person from
kolkata five percent from delhi
and there are 64 percent who are from
others
and which university are you currently
in so we have 28 person participants
today who are from the university of
ghana
and we have the rest of the participants
from different
uh universities around the world
and what what is your current degree
which is a fourth question
and we have 46 percentile
who are in a master's program which is
the highest number then we have
30 percent phds bachelor degree holders
are 20 percent
and 5 percent are others
while the research interest is the
highest in bioinformatics which is 75
percent followed by
genomics which is 46 percent followed by
uh the same percentile of 26 percent in
both biology and microbiology
while there are 23 percent who are
interested in
other research and regarding the
background which is the last
question we have 46 percent who are
researchers
joining us today and this is the highest
number
while 38 percent are students we have 10
percent faculty
and 3 percent industry while there are
also 3 percent
others so this is the poll result from
the session so far thank you elia
thank you i do also want to mention
uh that i see uh and maybe you could
put in the chat box again the links
to social media groups i see dorothea
obiri
from university of ghana pratik paul
um a student at sam higginbottom
university
ali al zaire biomedical informatics
doesn't say from where is my ismaila
adams uh data scientist and researcher
and
elio naimawura so those are the people
that have
joined the group and if you are still
not there so please join
uh the groups there on social media okay
so
let me address some of these questions
ahmad
giffary is asking about whole
genome sequence it's mentioned that we
can detect mutations related to
virulence
how are the researchers conclude their
findings from whole genome sequencing
into more transmittable virus
so i think here you're really talking
about association
between phenotype and genotype
so using whole genome sequencing we can
identify the mutations
by using other type of information for
example
rates of transmission or virulence
and those are going to be either
collected from the population like rates
of transmission or they could be
studied in the context of an experiment
so one of the things that we'll talk
about in our next session
is how this data is generated and we'll
see actually
how one of the examples will take data
from the ebola virus outbreak from 2014
to 2016.
as you know it's spread it in the west
africa and it was
the first example where an epidemic
was also paralleled with almost
real-time sequencing efforts so there
was a lot of data that was coming from
different groups
and we'll see how in the context of that
epidemic it's a good case study because
it started and it ended right it's not
the
like the ongoing pandemic that uh we're
still kind of looking at
so what we are going to look at is how
to
find those associations between uh
mutants mutations and the phenotype
but the overall idea is that you can do
for example controlled studies where you
understand the mechanism
or you can find an association and that
association could be using
something like genome-wide association
study where you
translate your phenotypic information
into numeric data and then there are
methods to find that using
a regression model let me go to the next
question quamite are
all infectious diseases necessarily
pathogenic organisms
from my veterinary background i know a
couple of diseases such as
canine general tumor taci
devil facial tumor these are infections
but not caused by pathogens
so again there might be exceptions
uh i do not come from a veterinary
background and
just kind of talking about the general
uh descriptions
uh but you know definitely interested to
learn more and i'll look into that
and if you have any more clarification
about those
examples that you mentioned please put
those in the chat that that really
sounds fascinating
um okay the other question is
how can i identify the position of
different regions of the gene
in sequence if no information about the
exact position
from reference papers so i think that
has to do with
uh genomes that are not well annotated
so you don't have
an annotation and you want to identify
how does a gene sequence fall
in the context of the full genome
perhaps right maybe you can clarify the
question
uh but i think the approach would be to
first
create an assembled genome so to
assemble either the whole
genome which could be very difficult in
some cases or at least
in context right so into portions that
are fairly large
uh the way it's done is using de bruyne
graphs
you can find a kind of in
short sequences of reads you can find
overlapping regions and connect them
together into longer sequences and so
depending on the length of the read the
coverage
other information that is available you
can probably piece together a fairly
good
uh portion and then try to map your
specific gene sequence onto that region
i think that that would be the general
approach um
okay how to identify the viral genes in
an
organism great question we'll talk about
that and today i'll introduce one of the
examples where you can actually find
a pathogen from another in infectious
in cell lines that are using for that
are being used for biologics production
so
let's get to that in just a couple of uh
minutes
by the end of this program will we be
able to identify
parasite genotyping sequencing so
my hope is that yes my hope is that
very soon into the program you will be
able to
take gene sequencing information so
information from a sequencer
and understand what type of parasite
this is or what type of
genome does it map to we'll take
take a look at a few examples where you
can map onto a database of viruses
or you can look at a database of
bacteria
so that way you will be able to identify
those
okay i'll take the last question how to
find snips in
exonic and intronic region okay
excellent question
as we all know genes are consist of
exons and introns and so if we have
whole
genome sequencing which includes the
full sequence both
exons and introns we can map them onto
the reference and identify those snips
if we only have exon sequencing or exome
sequencing
then we cannot but i think in general
you should be able to
given the right type of data again thank
you for all of these questions
i'll continue to make pauses like this
so if you
have a question as we go through the
slides please put them in the chat and i
will
try to address them as soon as we get to
a breaking point
all right let's talk about next
generation sequencing now again
in our next session we're going to talk
a lot more
about different types of sequencing and
how
that is used in different file formats
how those file formats could be
visualized and things like that today i
will give you a brief introduction
we have about 15 minutes to go through
the next set of slides
then i'll pause for a few more questions
and then i will pass it on to
uh and then i will show you how to
access different parts of
the resources that we have
okay so one of the things about
sequencing is that sequencing technology
can identify what are the specific
nucleotides
but the way the data is prepared
could be in many different ways and some
good examples
are targeted amplicon sequencing or
whole genome sequencing
so there are many different library
preparation techniques
that essentially mean that once the
genetic material the
biological material is collected and
dna or rna is extracted from that sample
that needs to go through several
additional steps
and those steps could determine what are
you in the end sequencing
and therefore how to analyze that data
so three major examples that we will
again look at
in much greater detail in our next
session are targeted sequencing
when a particular gene or even a
region of a gene is amplified using
pcr amplification and then once you do
the
reading of that sequence or the
sequencing itself
you are really trying to make sure that
first of all
you remove those sequences that helped
exclude those particular regions from
the rest
and you are dealing with the impact of
pcr amplification
on the number of reads that you're
getting from different regions
then you can map it onto a reference
genome
or if you know exactly which regions
have been amplified
you can only map it onto those reference
sequences so we'll take a look at that
at that
many times this is done for example in
the context of the current pandemic
people want to ask the question are
there particular
novel mutations appearing in the spike
region
right so they will amplify only the
spike protein
or they can ask the question in
wastewater
or in blood samples of patients could we
amplify
just covid19 or source cove to
genome in another case if you're looking
at the microbiome you might want to ask
the question about
the composition of the microbiome you
don't want to
survey any particular individual
representative of the microbiome but you
want to understand
how does the composition change does
this group of
bacteria become more prominent or less
prominent right and so then you can
amplify the 16s
ribosomal rna gene and that would be an
example of amplicon sequencing
for a whole dna in rna sequencing you
could sequence
all of the data that comes from let's
say again a human blood sample
but you could suspect finding specific
bacteria
or specific viruses and typically you
are likely to find
things like hepatitis virus maybe
epstein-barr virus and other types of
viruses and i'll show you an example
today from
maybe if we have time so those are
again important to understand because
when we find
data especially if we're dealing with
public repositories
we need to go through and understand
what was the method of preparing
such data before we try to analyze it
now the exciting part
is that there has been a tremendous
growth
of data in various repositories
both specific repositories like viral
repositories and databases
uh specific databases around different
types of diseases like malaria
or in general publicly available data on
the host response
vectors etc so i think it's an exciting
time for those that
know how to use bioinformatics because
what we need to understand
is that we should be able to find data
on
practically any pathogen that you're
interested in
likely somebody has sequenced it and so
there should be some information
obviously that's not true in a hundred
percent of the cases but in most of the
times that i've interacted with groups
of
people learning about a particular
domain we were able to find
some publicly available data and that
gives us
a head start right so you don't have to
start in a vacuum you really have
a repository where you can find a lot of
information
to deal with different types of data
now as i mentioned one of the additional
aspects of that is that we
have almost real time sequencing efforts
that allow us to sample uh pandemics and
epidemics and other types of
communicable diseases
almost in real time developing a sense
of what is going on and so one of the
first
things to do is to identify what is the
pathogen
and so here you can see that typically
one of the key aspects of identification
of the primary
mechanism or the primary pathogen is to
have a
full genome now it's not easy to
make a full genome if you just have
short read sequences available
so people typically rely on sanger
sequencing
and long read sequencing to establish
how do the different
pieces connect together after that is
done
you are typically able to find how
individual reeds map onto that reference
genome so here you can see
one of the first genomes that was
published for source code 2
it was essentially these little lines
here represent the individual reads
and those reads were mapped onto the
closest known genome so you can see that
this is beta corona virus from wuhan
right and so once you have all of these
short reads
mapped onto some kind of a reference you
can now
start asking the questions what is the
difference and so
there we'll take a look at many
different types of questions that you
can ask about the sequence
primarily around how is it different
and what is it that we are exp what are
we biologically studying
in this kind of data so one of the
things that now we need to turn to are
what are some of the analysis
methods that are available and again
let's go back to where we started
we talked about sequence variation and
primarily that's found
through sequence alignment but we'll see
how multiple types of
answers could be obtained from alignment
including what's called reconstruction
of
evolution and that could mean in the
context
of multiple samples or even an
individual sample as we will take a look
now the second question that you might
ask is once you've identified a region
of interest for example the spike
protein
how could you actually interpret the
impact of specific variants
on binding on maybe other structural
properties
of that particular protein because you
understand its function
and a way to study the function is to
study
the host response through transcriptomic
data analysis now in the context of this
program
we will be using the t-biome for
platform and the reason why we are going
to be using this platform
is because it will provide you a number
of tools that you can easily use without
any computational infrastructure just in
your browser
for very large data sets and so because
this is a research program
all of you that join the program will
have access to a personal
research account and so that means that
you will be able to upload
data sets with hundreds of samples
analyze those
without requiring your own computational
infrastructure and so we hope that as a
result of that
you'll not only learn about how this
data is generated and what it can give
you
but you'll actually do a lot of that
practical uh work yourself so
let me show you um first of all
what this platform is all about so
let's go to server.tbio
info and please let me know once you are
there
by putting number one or yes or i'm
there
in the chat box and i'll give it just a
couple of uh
minutes for everybody to get here beeps
if you could also share the demo
account details okay so
those of you that are a part of the
infectious disease program you've
already completed your registration
you should have gotten an email with
your account
so if you do have your account you
should use that account
you should log in with your email and
a password that you were given for all
the rest
that have not yet uh registered
registered
and want to kind of try this out you can
use the demo account
that beeps is showing right here that
she has pasted in the chat box
okay so i see one two three four five
six so let's give it a moment maybe
until we have at least 10 people there
[Music]
okay
okay has anyone else logged in
all right great we have 10 people
excellent so
as you look around this is the area of
analysis
you will see that this table represents
a number of different technologies that
generate data
and so you will see next generation
sequencing data
mass spectroscopy data structural
biology data
and then here you will see a number of
additional sections
for downstream analysis and application
to a particular type of data for example
in virology you will see this right here
so
in next generation sequencing data on
this side
for those of you that have a demo
account
login you will be able to follow along
using some of these demo pipelines for
those of you that have
a full account you will also later be
introduced
to how to upload your own data or a data
set from a public repository
and run these pipelines but just to kind
of give you a sense
of what this is let's take a look over
here under phylogenetic tree
okay and we'll take a look at this first
example
okay so here in the first example
again i'll go back and i will i open
this drop down
right so phylogenetic tree you can see
that the drop down
opens this up and i'm going to go to
phylogenetic analysis
okay and then once you're in here you'll
be
able to click on these buttons and
essentially
create a pipeline right so what is a
pipeline
a pipeline is something that connects
multiple steps into a sequence
of scripts so each button here
represents a script
and once you have created that script
it has been added to your pipeline
and this pipeline now could be executed
okay so this is just an example pipeline
you can see that the next step opens up
after you have completed the previous
step
okay so now i've run my pipeline
and this means that it is loading okay
so as you can see these are
different types of sections that deal
with
transcriptomic data analysis deal with
mutation variant analysis that deal with
different types of metagenomic data
analysis
amplicon data analysis and so you will
see how
in the context of this full program we
will use
a lot of these different sections to
understand
how they are applied in the context of
specific questions
research questions that you have so how
do you use the appropriate method
for answering that question now i'm not
going to necessarily go into this right
now but let me give you an
overview of what are some of these
methods of analysis
so that we understand what they do
so the first obvious one we kind of saw
that pop up there already
is alignment right so we take multiple
assembled sequences this is once we have
faster files
and we compare them to each other to
identify
regions that are dissimilar so here for
example you have
g's everywhere apart from this section
that has t's now this is at the
nucleotide level
and one of the questions that you
typically would ask is what is the
impact of this particular mutation on
the amino acid sequence because that
determines
determines function and that determines
protein structure
and so we'll learn about different types
of mutations and how those mutations
affect this amino acid sequence
as well as the codon structure in the
dna
so that we can understand what are the
specific
biases or typical expected rates of
mutation for example in viruses
in different codons another example
is when we deal with fastq files so when
we deal with fastq
files the actual reads in the data set
that we have
they actually represent uh
multiple variations that could be
common so they could be aligned between
multiple reads that have been sequenced
for example like here you have
the reference genome and in the
reference genome we have a t
and then in our reads we find one two
three
four five evidences for
a change in that position now sometimes
that change is not as clear-cut
here we have g and a and here we have a
c so the question is
what is this substitution right is this
a technical error
is this a real substitution what is it
and sometimes we also see evidence of
insertions and deletions that could be a
single nucleotide or multiple
nucleotides
and so really the way to deal with such
data is to run what's called
variant calling and so in the variant
calling analysis
what we are looking for is not
differences between
different assembled sequences
we are going to look for variance and
those variants are defined
by a a consensus
between the reads that that is higher
than the
threshold of technical variation that we
expect
as a result of technical issues with
sequencing accuracy
so when we look at such data
we want to identify where could such
variation come from
for example selective pressures like
antibacterial drugs antiviral drugs
immune responses
we can also ask the question about what
are they associated with
right we had a question before how do we
identify
a relationship or an association between
genotype
and phenotype we can talk about
how variants can play a role in
the structure for example it directly
affects the amino acid sequence
and maybe the chemical property of the
change is of it is changing
or maybe it is in a regulatory sequence
like the promoter region and even though
it doesn't affect the
exon it doesn't affect the protein it
still affects how
it is expressed how it is translated
and we can do what's called comparative
analysis so we can ask the question
if i have all of my uh all of my
variants for many samples how could i
divide them up into different groups and
compare them and maybe extract
the differential variance that i observe
in my data
so let's take a look at an example let's
say we have
replication so we have a virus
it's a pathogen the pathogen enters the
cell
inside the cell it replicates there is
an immune response
okay so one of the things that we can
ask is
if i know the sequence of the virus that
entered the cell
how can i study what came out of the
cell
and so when we look at this biological
scenario we can start asking the
question
what are the differences in the genomic
sequences
or maybe even more interestingly how can
we find
many different results as a result of
many different pathogens
living together in a single cell and
then
we actually observe a variety as a
result of the different
selective pressures and so the obvious
question if you extrapolate this
biological
question to many organisms
across a process of time is to start
reconstructing
not only what are the specific sequences
but also
how do they correlate to each other how
could we
organize this into some kind of a
biological model
essentially that is represented by the
data that we collect
and the data that we collect are the
genomic sequences of individual
genomes or viruses of bacteria etc
so phylogenetic tree reconstruction
first of all has
many different methods and two it could
be done
either by looking at the molecular clock
or
essentially what is the rate of
mutations that are accumulating across
the whole genome
or how do we maybe link it to real time
if we have real-time metadata we could
start finding associations between
molecular clock which is produced
computationally
and the real observation data which we
know from collecting different samples
and so in the context of this program
what we'll look at
is how are these trees generated so
you're probably familiar with
examples like this this is the source
code oh this is the ebola virus
outbreak and you can see here how it
separates into multiple clades
representing evolution
adaptation to the host because it
originated from a different host
common origin how maybe there was a
particular event
that caused this the split into
different uh
clades and what is the price of
divergence so ultimately
you can see that only specific ones
were the most successful at surviving
for a longer time
and so these examples are going to be
used as
case studies these case studies will
introduce you to the biological
kind of background will give you a sense
of what are the types of research
questions that we are going to ask and
then
how do we organize our bioinformatics
analysis to answer those questions
with the specific discovery and
with validation so where are we getting
these projects
these projects are taken from the public
domain again they're taking from
peer-reviewed
uh publications that typically include
the data so they describe how the data
was generated
why it was generated who generated it
right all the questions that we need to
know about data
what are the methods that they used to
analyze such data
and once you get a sense of how experts
and people that have spent
uh considerable time researching these
data sets
you can essentially start taking either
the same data
or combine it with other types of data
and the same methods or new methods that
you have learned
and develop what's called a project of
your own
and the idea here is to first of all
focus on projects that are novel and
independent but within the context of
particular examples
that we have covered in these sessions
now some of these examples include
things like
some of these examples include
things like the novel coronavirus so
again these are
projects beeps if you could put the link
to the projects
for people to take a look at that where
we essentially
take some of the um some of the data
sets
that were used to kind of ask the
question about
origin we look at how
the different strains from bats
from pangolin from source code 2 were
compared to each other
we looked at how those helped identify
most dissimilar regions and what were
some of the conclusions about the
origin we also looked at how that
was translated to an understanding of
the 3d structure impacts right so how
could this
be an evidence for example for
adaptation between different species
right so essentially what we will do is
we will take a look at
divergence at the genomic level we will
also take a look at
structural compounds and
what important what is important is
we'll try to piece this information
together with available structures of
proteins right so for example you've
probably all heard about the h2 receptor
so we'll take a look at the model
of the h2 receptor how it's actually a
complex and the complex
includes the bo at1 sodium dependent
neutral amino acid transport
transporter and that's where we will uh
apply some uh computational magic
to align known structures to each other
and understand how does the virus
actually bind to this complex and how
what does it actually
do so we'll take a look at these
examples
and kind of identify the important
functional domains
in these proteins that we all heard
about and we all hear people talk about
all the time so
that's one example uh obviously we have
a whole project on the evolution of
ebola virus
and how such analysis could be
replicated
again the phylogenetic tree is just one
visual that people use but there's a lot
more
questions that you could specifically
ask
for example uh what are some of the
haplotypes right so how could we
identify
differences between strains that are
more
effective at replicating or less
effective at replicating
by comparing them not in terms of
individual variants
but in terms of their com composition
right so here you can see
more haplotype diversity here you can
see less haplotype diversity
and in fact we will also follow through
some literature review
where these types of issues were
highlighted right so we're not proposing
something completely new
but we're actually linking it back to
some of the research that already
validated some of these same findings
now importantly we'll look at other
hypotheses that were proposed
during those outbreaks right where
people said
we're so concerned with airborne
transmission for example right or a
particular mutation can have such an
impact or another kind of impact today
kind of
looking back it's much easier to take a
look at this data
look at the specific mutations that have
come up
in the data and try to see whether
that's the direction to continue
research
or where where does that lead us
now another example that we'll use is in
tuberculosis
as an example of drug resistance so
tuberculosis has
single drug resistance multiple drug
resistance and this is a common issue
in many different pathogens so we've
kind of
assembled a number of examples from
these different types of
data sets viral data sets uh
bacterial datasets um parasites
like uh malaria so we'll introduce you
to those data sets in our next
session we'll take a look at different
sequencing technologies so
really to understand what is the data
that we're dealing with
now what we want from you today is
to start thinking about a project of
your own now
many of you are researchers many of you
are working perhaps on your phd
or already doing some research work so
what we want to know
early on is what are the specifics
about your research question uh beeps if
you could post the link
to uh this on the forum so again
this is primarily for those that have
already completed your registration
and i'll just show you how to find this
form where you can submit this
information
so again this is for those of you that
have already registered
if you go to the same educational
portal as we were on before where we
looked at
the introduction to bioinformatics
course
i will show you how there is a specific
dedicated area for all of you that are
part of the group so
what where you should go is under events
there's a list of programs and so the
program
here that we're talking about is
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
naguchi
so you click on here under programs
and you will find the information
specifically about the program
found right here and here you will find
different types of updates
so for example you can see that beeps
have posted here a number of videos
that we have done already in the free
webinars related to this program
uh and you will also find different
types of activity
from different participants of the
program
but what we are talking about right now
is this section on the forum
so here on the forum you can ask
questions
you can ask uh you know there was
trouble with something you can post it
here
there are some resources here and an
important part here is the project
submission form
so the project submission form is
essentially there to help you
structure your ideas about your research
topic into an organized form that we
will review
and one of our mentors either harpreed
or muhit will reach out to you
to make sure that we address all of the
different
parts of this submission of this
proposal
so here you will find project title
the problem statement what exactly are
you trying to do and why
the project summary where was the data
what is the data
how many samples do you have what kind
of analysis are you proposing to do
links to the raw data so we can check
whether the data could be used to answer
your research question
and any reference reference publication
so we know that you've done your
literature review
so the main thing here is to really help
you organize your information in such a
way that
an external reviewer can take a look
evaluate and provide you with
some feedback on what you're trying to
do
okay so let me briefly summarize what
are the important program resources
that you should be getting access to and
again
any questions about these resources you
should be asking
from beeps so she's the community
manager
she will give you your login information
if you don't have it
she will guide you to where to complete
your registration
right so if you don't know this program
registration
how to finish your registration reach
out to her it's marketing and find out
bio
if you don't know where to find a
particular project that i showed
i've shown you resources from everything
that's already available so you can ask
her
again we'll take a look at all of these
different things
but if you have any questions reach out
to her now as i mentioned
omix logic is not just about
training it's not just theoretical
training it's just not
you know acquiring skills it is really a
community
and so what's important is as you are
getting started with these different
resources
we're asking you to complete your
profile and when you complete your
profile you're not doing it for us
you're doing it for yourself
we want other people to be able to find
you in the program
list and know that this person is from
this university or this lab that's what
they're doing maybe that's their social
media profile right
we hope that you can connect to each
other because ultimately in
any bioinformatics research project
there's going to be collaboration and a
collaboration
is a big part of what we are trying to
help you establish here as well
there are many international researchers
students
and faculty from many different
universities so we're really hoping that
you could connect
now the basic tools that we already
talked about
are the server account where you can run
big data analysis and courses
these are practical courses if you're
not familiar with the basics
how to do alignment what types of
mutations to expect
what are variations in gene expression
those are the types of questions that
are going to be covered
in these courses they will provide you
also with quizzes
that you can answer to know that you
have understood the material
you can answer those questions they will
also provide you with
assignments those practical assignments
will most likely use the server
analytical platform
to show you how this analysis is done
and make sure that you can submit your
assignments
to get feedback on this pro
on this program page so on this program
page you will find
the resources specifically around
this group of people this program so
here you will find
things like the forum and the courses
that are included there
different project examples that we have
discussed
and you will also see how you can track
your
activity so let me show you what that
actually looks like
okay and thank you beeps that has posted
the link
okay so here you have this menu
in this menu you can find the courses
and these are courses that are included
in this
program right so if you have not
completed the registration you have to
complete the registration first before
you have access to this
so genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
etc so you will find some of these
courses right here
there are also a number of project
examples so these project examples
are going to introduce you to some case
studies
and those case studies are going to help
you understand how it was done in the
context of a particular research
question now a lot of these
might not necessarily be related to
viruses or bacteria or anything like
that but they will
illustrate how such analysis could be
used
okay what is inside these courses
inside these courses we explain
the rationale and objective why are we
learning about a particular data type
and what is the terminology and the
biological context
you will see engaging activities that
will help link
the specific topics and concepts to
what you are going to do so that the
analysis you do
is based on logic then we're going to
include a data set
or a project with an explanation of
where it came from and what
is this data and you will understand
what are some databases research
publications and project examples as
well as file formats
then you will run an analysis pipeline
and that will help you establish the
logic of how these different steps
are connected into a single workflow and
you will be able to see some examples of
outputs that you need to look through to
understand what was
in the data and finally it will provide
you with a
point system so that you can compare
your progress to the overall progress of
the group so
one of the important things that we have
found
is that consistency and returning to
the assignments regularly helps you
understand and become more proficient so
i'll just show you
what that looks like for example
you can look through
you can look through some of these
example profiles i will just show you
uh you know what a profile of
a typical participant would look like
and i see that somebody has already
completed their profile jeff
so let's take a look at jeff's profile
sorry jeff for putting you on the spot
here but uh
hopefully others can learn from your
experience already
uh so jeff has uh joined and you can see
that he has
300 points right and so those points are
from
completing the profile registering on
the platform
and now you can see what courses he is
taking now i'm not going to show you
everything because
things like quiz results and assignments
are going to be proprietary to his
that's his progress
but you can still kind of get a sense of
what he's doing so he's enrolled
in a number of these courses and as he
continues to build up his profile you
will start seeing
progress in those courses now here are
some
of the top profiles you can see
we have a leaderboard of the top 100
participants
from all over the world you will see
that they are from many different
regions in the world
and really anyone can start with this
process for free essentially and with
minimal basic subscription you can get
started so you can see here
different people that have a number of
points and the change in those points
and uh you will see all the way to
the last person in this list
and that's about 14 000 points right so
if you want to be on this list
we'll feature you once you get to this
list once you get essentially over 10
000 points we will feature you but you
can take a look at some of these
examples
and what these people have been able to
do through the course of this program
okay so let me pause and see if there
are any questions
and beeps if you could please launch or
never mind i can launch
i think this second poll so we have
another poll
uh this is on feedback so
i'm going to ask uh for you to be
um very honest uh so we are looking to
improve these sessions and make sure
that the sessions are informative
and useful for what you're trying to do
so the first question is how would you
rate the session
i will not be offended so you can uh
you know tell me that was very poor
if you did not like it
the second question is what did you like
the best about
the session so if you like how the topic
was presented
um or it was specifically related to
infectious disease research um and
if you didn't learn anything new that's
also fine we would like to know
and then the question number three is
what is your expectation
from the program so if you would like to
learn about new bioinformatics tools
or you want to get introduced to
virology research or gain basic
understanding of bioinformatics if
you're just getting started
so those are some of the questions
please try to answer these questions
in the poll itself and i'm going to
leave this on here for
a few more minutes for anyone to be able
to
look through and also if you have any
questions
right so i'm here to try and answer any
of the questions that you have
and after the questions i will
introduce you to one other resource that
i think you will find
interesting and relevant to what we're
going to do and give you an assignment
for our next time
as the feedback is going on we have a
question here from
ahmad gifari regarding the pipeline
how to note down the procedure in the
methods
section of publication i'm not quite
sure if that refers to the pipeline
okay so as i understand the question is
let's say
you use the pipeline to analyze your
data
and you want to report how you've
generated
that data so one of the useful things
i'll just give you an example with my
pipeline
i used a pipeline
for mapping data
from wastewater treatments to identify
sars growth 2
and this is a part of a publication so
i'm going to report on it
so the good thing is that first of all i
have a reproducible workflow
so these are the individual methods i
use bowtie to align
and then pause count and names replace
and i will find
a report on this pipeline right here
so each pipeline has a report so in that
report
i will see which version of the method
was used
what was the input data what was the
output data and how
long did it take for this to run and you
also referenced the t bioinfo platform
which was developed
at the talmud bioinformatics research
center so here you can
use that as a reference for running it
on this server
okay so the question from francis uh-huh
can the project be a systematic review
in the field of bioinformatics
uh yes so again a systematic review in
the field
the field of bioinformatics i would say
is humongous it has been around for
decades there are many different tools
databases
and applications of bioinformatics and i
would say that
you know you can definitely attempt an
overview a systematic review of
bioinformatics but i would
rather recommend a focused approach so
if you first of all learn about the
general applications of bioinformatics
through the introduction to
bioinformatics course
there you will see different types of
methods applications
databases data types etc so once you
have
done that you can also focus
for example on bioinformatics for
infectious diseases right
and there you can do some systematic
review
right so i think it depends on really
what is your primary objective and your
focus
and since you're already a registered
participant in the program
i think we'll be able to develop that
idea further
after a few more sessions
do we have results uh on the uh poll
yes we do have uh results on the poll
and i see that there are still uh
participants who are still voting okay
let me answer a couple of these
questions hold on let's just wait on
until we have
how many percent overall have answered
we have uh 58 percent who have voted so
we can wait for a few more okay thanks
okay so let's take a look at these
questions how do i apply bioinformatics
in plant breeding research
i think that's a good question obviously
genotyping right so looking at
established mutations in particular
genes could be very useful
but if we talk about the infectious
diseases
there are many infectious diseases that
are specifically
for uh uh or
sorry yeah plant breeding right so there
they are viruses that affect for example
different plants
there are microbes that are used as
fertilizers
uh we we had a session uh yesterday
on uh metagenomics where we talk about
the application of microbiome studies in
different domains including agriculture
so i think that there are a lot of
applications and one of the projects
that we have
you can start looking at it right here
under projects
if you go to all of the projects
or actually right here on the very top
you can see crop drought stress
and resistance so this is a
transcriptomic study right here and that
transcriptomic study
helps you understand differences between
drought
resistant and less resistant strains of
potato
cultivars
okay another question good afternoon can
be possible to
feel the virology be able to grow the
interest and grow in the field
yes so this program is specifically
designed for people that you know
are not technically maybe uh versed in
bioinformatics
so if you're already in the field of
virology
uh maybe beep say you could post a link
on how to complete the registration
to this program on bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
this would be a great start for you
learning about bioinformatics and trying
to apply it to
your particular area of research
we have another question anna from jeff
so jeff's question is as we are thinking
of the project
is it advisable to come up with a
project on clinical trials
i think the main question about clinical
trials is availability of data
can you actually get access to raw data
to do the analysis because a lot of
clinical trials
will only report data after they have
completed
okay i'm a bioinfo student but i don't
have money to afford it but i have
willingness to learn and explore is
there any aid or free resources
yes first of all there are many free
resources please join for free
and you have access to a number of
introductory courses for free and i'll
introduce you in a second here to our
coding platform
where you can also practice some of the
coding and see how these things are
applied
in the context of r and python
uh we also have an assistance program a
a scholarship program
intended specifically for people that
have financial needs
uh beeps if you could paste the link to
our scholarship request form
excellent thank you okay so let's take a
look at the poll results if we can
uh beeps
yes okay so as for the first question
how would you rate this session
so we see that 59 percent of our
participants have
said that they found the session very
informative 22 percent said that they
found the section
excellent while 14 percent to give it a
good
which is a three and five person says it
was okay
moving on to the second question what
did you like best about the session
51 person says that i like how the topic
was presented
27 percent says that the session
introduced
them to infectious diseases research
and 22 person said that they're already
familiar with the topic
and the session had to add to their
knowledge
and regarding the third question which
is what is your expectation
from the program 57 percent
of the participants want to learn about
new bioinformatics tools
while the next 30 person wants to learn
or gain
basic understanding of bioinformatics
and
14 person wants to get introduced to
biology research
so that's the poll er all right thank
you very much so
thank you for the feedback those of you
that did not like the session
really did not have to come you know i'm
just joking so
um hopefully next session is going to be
more informative i will try to improve
if you send me some specific
recommendations or how
on how we can do this better we would be
very glad to
look through and address your comments
so briefly
let me now actually introduce you to the
last resource
on the list if you could go with me to
code.omicslogic.com
so a big part of what we do
is going to be based on big data
analysis and one of the challenges in
big data analysis
is infrastructure another challenge
is coding proficiency to deal with data
okay thank you uh beeps for posting the
link
you can also register here for free so
please let me know once you are here
and you have registered now for those of
you that are part of the omixlogic
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program
at university of ghana you should use
the exact same email address
as you are using for your registration
okay please let me know once you have
registered and i should
get here a notification if you are
registering
so uh please go to this link
and let me know once you are in
and once you're in what you should see
is
this list of courses and i'll kind of go
through
and give you uh just a very brief
example of what we will be doing during
the program okay so
let me know if you have registered
if you're already registered just maybe
put yes i'm there
in the chat box so i know that you're
there
all right thank you francis anyone else
all right excellent
okay i'll wait for a couple more minutes
for everybody to get here
what this is is a collection of
similar topics that are explained
more at the script level so
you will see here simple courses like
getting started for example where you
can
load data and visualize it and maybe
read dna sequences in r
and one of the things that we would like
to ask you to do if you have completed
your registration
is to take a look at this course called
genomics so some of the things that we
are going to be doing in the context of
this program
is looking at variance and looking at
structure and things like that so i'm
going to go through this uh brief lesson
to just kind of explain how this works
you'll learn here about dna structure
what are the mutations and things like
that
you'll also learn that dna is organized
into chromosomes
and what does that mean in terms of
different variants
and where they are in the codons and
it will be followed by a quiz
so here you'll learn some theoretical
things and you can know that this is a
theoretical lesson
if it has this learn tag right here
but then you want to practice how does
this actually
uh work in r for example so here
when you get to this uh stage you'll see
how
for example we can assign specific
strings of characters to
a uh an object right
and you can for example print that
object now
sometimes you want to compare those
sequences and here we go through
an explanation of pairwise alignment
first
okay and and here's an example so how
does this
work here you are loading a specific
library
and you're putting in some strings in
here and then
you have to click on run and it will
actually run right here in the browser
so after you click the run button it
will provide you
with the result and you can see that you
have here success this code has been run
successfully
so as you go through these exercises
they will become a little bit more and
more advanced
as you go through so once you go through
you complete you go to the next one
that is a little bit more challenging
for example
let's go to the next one okay here we're
dealing with multiple sequences so here
we have three
different sequences okay let's try to
run this just as an example
okay so now instead of just the output
you also have this link right here down
at the bottom
actually shows you the sequence and
shows you where the difference is
okay so these types of activities are
also connected to your profile and you
will see
under your profile that these activities
are going to add points to your overall
progress
okay so the link to registration this is
the link to register to this particular
coding
playground what we call coding
playground but also
if beeps say you could send a link to
the registration for the program okay
so as you go through you will then find
a challenge
so here you see final assignment here
you're given a
specific situation you have metabolism
of drugs
and your goal is to identify which
mutation
is going to cause problems for
metabolism of drugs
okay so here you'll see that you
actually have to
write your own code and figure it out
right so in such a way we hope that
you'll be able to
practice some of the code understand how
this code is applied
to a particular problem statement and
then
practice your coding so that you learn
how to do it on your own
so again the goal of this program is to
introduce you
to a lot of the areas of bioinformatics
like the tools for big data analysis
where you will run pipelines and
understand how they're
operating as well as practice different
types of analysis in r
and in python including some of the
things that we
just looked at and i hope that most of
you will be
taking the time after this session to
complete your profile
and make sure that we're getting started
with this program
ready for your research
project so this is the assignment for
our next session
complete your educational profile on the
t-biling phone
two take the free course introduction to
bioinformatics and fill out that survey
we want to know more about you about
your research interest
and three familiarize yourself with the
tbi info server and the codomix logic
playground
so those are the last two resources that
we just had
and to remind you this program starting
today
january 29th will go through
sequence variation and alignment
evolutionary and phylogenetic analysis
functionality and protein structure
including the physical chemical
properties of proteins
and transcriptomic analysis of host
response
again thank you everyone for joining
today we went a little bit
over our time but i will pass it on to
deepsea to kind of take over and answer
any technical questions unfortunately i
have another meeting to go to but
for those of you that like this session
i thank you for your
feedback those of you that did not like
the session
i am looking forward to your specific
feedback what you think should be
improved
and you can email me directly by going
by emailing elia
at pine.bio and i'm going to look
uh forward to learning from you as well
beeps over to you yeah thank you so much
helia so i will quickly start by sharing
my screen
so for any of you who are having
problems with logging into code dot
omics logic
when you go to the site for the first
time right now i am logged in
you will notice a get started button you
do not need to use the password that you
have for edut bio info
or the tbi info server you need to
create
a new login it will send a password
reset link to your email and from then
on
you would not need any password to log
into the site it will register your
email id
so please try that post the session
so that we are able to help you with
this
if you face any kind of problems with
this
login and please note that your edutbio
info login is separate from your tbio
info login
which is the server platform but one
thing is similar for
all of these three platforms which is
your email id
so please make sure that you're
utilizing the same email id
the edut buyer info the tbio info and
the omix logic code platform should have
the same email id